-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
Let's get to some news.
Well, this is very exciting.
"Time" magazine named
our good friend Olivia Rodrigo
the 2021
Entertainer of the Year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, for all the Olivia Rodrigo
fans out there,
"Time" magazine is for --
[ Laughter ]
It's for people who got their
driver's license 50 years ago.
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news -- today, the new
"Sex and the City" series
premiered on HBO Max.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. That's good.
Meanwhile, Netflix just released
a true-crime documentary
called
"What Happened to Samantha?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right. Carrie, Miranda,
and Charlotte are back,
but, unfortunately,
Samantha's not there
because of supply-chain issues.
[ Laughter ]
The first episode
addressed the pandemic,
and you can tell
it had an effect on Carrie
'cause now her shoe closet's
just filled with Crocs.
[ Laughter ]
So much has changed
since the show's first run.
Between the finale and now,
Michael Strahan went from
football player to astronaut.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and get this, guys.
You hear about this?
Tinder is rolling out
a new feature that will let you
hear someone's anthem song
before you swipe left or right.
[ Light laughter ]
It's supposed to be the song
that describes you best.
So it's a little concerning
when you hear...
-♪ I'm a creep ♪
♪ I'm a winner ♪
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, also,
if you don't like the song,
then you'll be swiping...
-♪ To the left, to the left ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, women are like,
"Yeah, this is great,
but I'd rather hear why he's 40
and still living at home."
[ Laughter ]
Well, I saw that
a man in London is selling
an ugly Christmas sweater
made from silk, gold thread,
diamonds, and crystals
for about $40,000.
Here it is.
Here's a photo of it.
Yeah.
Yeah, usually if you're spending
40 grand on something,
you don't want it
to have the word "ugly"
in the title, right?
[ Laughter ]
It's like,
"Here's my ugly Ferrari."
[ Laughter ]
It's the only thing
worth 40 grand that you don't
have to worry about
anyone stealing.
[ Laughter ]
It actually took the guy
3,000 hours to make.
Yep. People are trying to decide
if the sweater
is a bigger waste
of time or money.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I read that New York City
postal workers
have been accused of stealing
credit cards from the mail
and spending nearly a million
dollars on luxury items.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That explains why the mailman
tipped me for Christmas.
I was wondering.
[ Laughter ]
I knew something was up
when my mailman
showed up at my house
wearing a jet pack
and that ugly Christmas sweater.
I go...
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
a woman is suing Heineken
because she says their
alcohol-free beer
contains .03% alcohol.
Yep. She was like,
"I drank 200 of these, and..."
[ Laughter ]
"...totally embarrassed myself
at work."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show!
Guys, we have a big announcement
for tomorrow night's show.
The 46th President
of the United States
joins me for his first
late-night appearance
since taking office.
President Joe Biden is on
"The Tonight Show"
tomorrow night!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
But first, what a show
we have for you tonight.
They are the host of
"Miley's New Year's Eve Party,"
hosted by Miley Cyrus
and Pete Davidson,
which airs, live,
starting at 10:30 p.m.
New Year's Eve on NBC
and Peacock,
Miley Cyrus and Pete Davidson
are here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love both of them.
-We're gonna talk to them.
And then, later in the show,
Miley is performing
with The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, a special song for us.
-I love them.
Plus, he stars in the new movie,
"The Matrix Resurrections,"
which is in theaters
and on HBO Max December 22nd.
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II
is here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Got to choose.
He's awesome.
It's great.
Guys, we have exactly
seven shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 7 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an iconic Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown
to Christmas" cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm not saying
it's worth $40,000,
but it's pretty awesome.
Since there
are seven shows left,
let's open door number 7.
You ready for this, pal?
-I'm ready.
-Let's do it.
[ Drum roll ]
Oh, no, wow!
-Oh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause,
audience groans ]
[ Band plays off-key ]
[ Audience groans ]
♪♪
Uh, wow.
That's beautiful, that one.
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Is there something on the back?
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, another one.
Another little
scary something --
[ Cheers and applause ]
At least he's happy.
All right, at least he's happy.
[ Applause ]
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
[ Laughter ]
You have to take the sweater
if you get it.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone, look at
your seat number, please.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
Here we go.
Seat number 126.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
Come on down!
♪♪
Hi! Welcome!
Thank you very much
for being here.
Seat number 126.
What is your name?
-I'm Ali.
-Ali, where are you from?
-I'm from Virginia,
but I live in New York now.
-Oh, you're in New York
right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, today --
today, especially,
it got really cold out.
I thought it felt very wintry.
You don't have anything
like that at home, do you?
-No.
This is my first one of these.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Here's the good news --
it goes with everything.
-Oh, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Would you like to try it on?
-I would love to try it on.
-Yeah, I'm sure.
Roots, can we just --
I think it'll be perfect.
Yeah, you throw it on your --
-Are you good?
-Yeah.
There's no wrong way to wear it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure
if there's a right way, either.
-This is good.
-Oh, I can --
I can already feel
this is gonna work out.
Wait.
You make it look -- hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You make it look pretty good.
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about, Ali!
You make it look great, buddy!
I love it!
-Thank you!
-Congratulations once again
to our winner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stick around.
We're playing "True Confessions"
with Miley Cyrus
and Pete Davidson
after the break.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪